I will be hosting the event for Live Broadcast Flow Cytometry Fundamentals
from Parallel to Yesterday Iyo is the Ark Where Labo Tool's Judy Lives
Sponsored by labo tools and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific  Thank you for participating in this webinar
Thermo Fisher Scientific is an international company with approximately 50,000 employees in 50 countries
and revenues of approximately $7 billion.
Our mission is to enable our customers
to advance life science research, solve complex analytical problems, improve patient diagnostics and improve quality
of life and productivity.
Through top brands such as scientific Applied Biosystems, invitrogen unity, and lab services,
we offer the best combination of innovative technology gradients, convenience, and comprehensive support
.  Please visit our
website www.thermofisher.com Now, before we start the webinar, we have 23 important announcements.
If
you click the green q & a button at the bottom left of the presentation screen, a
q & a box will appear, so
please write your question in that box and send it.
Click the icon in the lower right corner of the slide screen to enlarge
If you cannot see the presentation screen or hear the audio due to monthly problems, please click
the support bot 1 in the upper right corner of the screen
or the green q & in the lower left corner Click the a button to submit your issue
Now let me introduce today's speaker, Jolin Bradford.
Since joining Bradford c in 2001
for flow cytometry platforms
He is passionate about trend analysis and has advocated many seminars and seminars on the subject.
Recently, I
have been
focusing on the development of acoustic cytovetry and equipment, and I am working on its application
. Thank you for participating in the Bell seminar.
First of all, I would like to introduce STAR is fisher scientific's protein and cell analysis business.
Today, I will talk about the basics of flow cytometry, which will help us to provide
solutions every step of the way, from experiment planning, sample preparation, detection data analysis, to service and support
.  It's just part of the promise, so today
we're going to
talk about what flow cytometry is, think about the basics of trends and how to interpret fluorescence spectra
, look at the components of a procytometer, and display data.  I'm going to look at the methods and I'm going
to talk about the common controls you need
in your procytometry experiments.
Well, cytometry is simply the measurement of cells, and
the reason we use the word pro is that cells are measured when they are flowing in a fluid stream on a plateau
. Flow cytometry is used in a wide variety of applications.
This makes flow cytometry one of the most useful and versatile
platforms available
by pushing this cell through the procytometry bar laser beam every second
and capturing the light each cell emits as it passes.  Perform the analysis The
ability to measure thousands or even millions of cells in a sample makes low cytometry the most
powerful platform available
Collected data is processed by software  Reporting all properties allows for statistical analysis
Most measurements use fluorescent labels
Some of the advantages of procytometry include recording data from a single cell Measuring large numbers of
cells  It can,
among other things, allow you to analyze your cells very quickly.
You can get rich statistical analyzes of
populations of cells
.
You can also look at populations, which is
great for naturally suspended blood cells and other cells,
and the data can be stored and reanalyzed at a later date
.
Trends are a kind of molecular process called a fluorochrome.
Fluorescent probes,
or fluorochromes, are
designed to bind within specific sites of the cell and respond only to specific stimuli.
Both absorption and emission spectra are
crucial to understanding how flow cytometry works.
So the Stokes shift is the difference between the excitation wavelength and the fluorescence ripple.
Let me give you a little more detail to help you understand the concept of fluorescence.
Wavelength is the distance that light travels in one oscillation cycle, measured in nanometers.
First, the visible light spectrum consists of light with wavelengths in the range of about 400 to
700 nm.
Short wavelength bands with high frequency and high energy.
Long wavelength bands with low frequency and low
energy.
This rigid control
is based on segregation of species. A
fluorochrome is a molecule that can fluoresce. In its
ground state, the fluorochrome is in a stable state.
No trend is
emitted. Light from an external source, such as laser light, fluoresces.  When it hits a dye, it absorbs that light energy.If
it absorbs enough energy, it becomes a higher energy invitation.This
is called an excited state.This process is
called Reiki.
It
tries to return to a lower state. The
excess energy is dumped, but the energy is released as light. The
emitted light is lower in energy and
longer than the light it absorbs.
So this is a cyclical process.
This can be summarized as follows:
transient lifetime with partial loss
of fluorochrome excitation energy due to absorption of light energy  It's a return to the pristine ground state,
so the emission maximum from the fluorophore is always at a longer wavelength,
which is lower energy than the light at the excitation wavelength that's absorbed.
So the fluorochrome actually absorbs a band of light energy, and we call
this the excitation electromagnetic, and it's
emitted over a band of wavelengths called the emission range
, which includes the cold maximum and o 2 .  Since the
excitation wavelength and the emission leaf tea are different, the Kyushu and emission ports are detected as different colors on the blackcurrant vector
.
The excitation spectrum and emission spectrum of the fluorochrome have
Contains important and
useful information about the
wavelengths of light required  Particular care must be taken when using the same in experiments, and ensuring that
the fluorophores are excited in a way that causes distinct emissions, as
provided by the Thermo Fisher website.  A spectrum
viewer would be very helpful. In
this particular example,
two fluorochromes are shown, Alexa Bath 488 and Alexa Flow 647.
Based on this same example here are the emission spectra for both alexa flow 488 and alexa flow 647
this is added to the spectrum viewer cover information
this is really important when building closed cytometry panels and designing experiments
It's a process, so
I'm adding here the Nakasu bandpasses that are commonly used in flow cytometers,
so you can see which trends both stations are
actually being collected by the specific bandpasses in
your cytometer.  Flow cytometry is a technique that can measure and analyze multiple properties of a single cell through
its components, basically fluidics,
optics, electronic wide-angle, fluidics that transport the cell to the
point of interaction.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh  It helps generate and collect,
and then the electronics convert that signal into an electronic form that's ready for computer analysis.
Then it's
discarded.
Optical techniques include light scattering and portable laser sources, which also direct and mediate the light at detectors.
So the purpose of the fluidics technology is to transport Mr. Lil
Inject the sample into the millennial stream
To get the optimal trajectory, try to bring the particle 5 laser beams to the center of the beam into
one particle.  You should only pass the racer height at a certain time
Also make sure the fluid system is free of debris and debris
Here is a diagram of the liquid flow on the left On the
right is the concealment and logitech delay nxt flow cytometer  There's a bottle for the fluids that we use in
fluidics systems, and there's a new century in fluidics systems, and it's usually saline, and in
most systems, the cells are completely
wrapped in the c century.
Pass the last ray through and scatter the light through the candidate k candidate to expose
the optics using cold air to create an illuminated area,
which may include a laser or diode, or
even a lens to focus the laser beam onto the cell at the intersection point.
In-
flight optics deliver a light signal to a specific detector
These include collection lenses and optical filters
Mirrors used to direct light to a specific detector
Most flow cytometers excite a racer  It's used as a human
, meaning the amplification of light by stimulated emission of radiation.The
most commonly used lasers
include, but are not limited to, 488 nanometer
red 638 nanometer
violet 405 nanometer
yellow 561 nanometer lasers.
Since the site meter is designed to be secondary, more and more systems are being used
Most lasers in multi-laser cytometers are spatially separated lasers
Different axes can pass through each laser's interaction point  can
The information obtained at each laser interaction point is adjusted in time so that the recorded events can be adjusted as the cell passes each
racer.
use line lasers instead of these today, but
this complicates emission and stain selection.
Now, the optical filters that direct the emitted trends are shown in the diagram on the left,
which also captures the light and converts it into a pulsed signal.  The detector on the right is shown in the diagram on the right. As the
cell passes through the laser, it refracts light in all directions and
spawns. The extent to which this occurs depends on the physical properties of the cell or particle, its
size and internal complexity.  Because
normally we look at forward scatter and side scatter.
Forward scatter is
the light that spawns forward when the racer hits the cell.
The magnitude of forward scatter is proportional to the parrot's cell or particle size.
Side-scattered light is defined as light that spawns at a larger angle,
which is usually collected at an angle from the line of passage of the racer.
In
the example on the left this shows 3 different cell populations in a lysed human whole well
.  is presented by a light scattering method that does not use a molding method,
and on the right side there are multiple old cut cells, and both of the cut cells are displayed.The
intersection point is the very heart of this system.  This is
where the laser and sample intersect. Optics run through
the resulting scattered light and fluorescence.
For the most accurate coverage of the data,
each particle or cell should pass through the laser beam at this point, one at a time.
Most cytometers
achieve this by injecting a stream of sample recruiting cells into the c
century Hydrodynamic Focusing Injects the sample into the c century with hydrodynamic focusing
Envelops the sample completely The
sample core is placed directly in the center of the c century
Based on the principle of Soryu, the sample core is
always separated in the new century This cousin flow
accelerates the particles to the center of the sample height  limit to  This process is known as the
dynamics focus of the
phyto.
At low flow rates, the sample height is narrow and the
particles optimally interact with the laser light.
The velocity of remains unchanged, but
rather
widens the sample core,
allowing more peaks to enter the sample stream at a given time.
This speed and sensitivity limitation
has been accepted by the flow cytometry community as
the lowest signal of any conventional system using the idle dynamics system.  In
order to obtain the best functional data with variability it is necessary to run at the lowest sample rate.In
2010 a breakthrough was announced which utilizes sound waves
regardless of speed or the grave of Mr. Procore.
The cells are very gently placed in the center of the sample flow by applying the cells to
the center of the flow by ultrasound
. After moving to the center of the flow beforehand.
These two forces combine to provide an extremely narrow particle stream and uniform laser irradiation regardless of the
c c c century stream Separate the cellular septic regulation from the centrifugal stream  The system
can be up to 10 times faster while still maintaining high quality of the data if inspected by ,
this is a capillary with 5 micron fluorescent beads flowing,
first without sonic waves, then with sonic waves.
You can see the particles aligning in the center.
First with speech, then with sound waves. As
you can see, the tuning fork aligns the cells in the fluid stream.
Its function is to convert the optical signal proportionally into the electronic
form.
Enables interfacing with a computer
Optical signal is generated when particles pass racer height in fluid flow
Particles enter laser light and scatter light
Or a low voltage pulse occurs when emitting a trend
This translates into a pulse signal
A few other definitions you need to know when talking about voltage
pulses The height of the pulse is the amplitude of the apex The
pulse area is  is the integrated signal of the pulse peak and the
time it takes for the pulse to pass through the
laser.Most cytometers calculate the width, but most nxt cytometers measure the skin directly.Trend
data is general.  Collected essentially in the same way as the front and side oviposition data.
There are bright and dark spots in the population of labeled moon cells.
When each cell intersects the laser path, a
fluorescent signal is generated.
is directed to the appropriate case where it is converted to a voltage pulse proportional to the amount of emission propensity
Procytometry data are
stored according to a defined standard called a Flow Cytometry Standard File or fcs file
which describes flow cytometry data.
All software vendors use this standard in creating files so that they can be analyzed by different software package libraries
Histograms are the most commonly used form of data presentation
It can be in various forms as shown in the slide stocks.
Histograms allow us to see many events with one parameter.
Histograms are also called Taichi parameter graphs.
You can draw a line around a population to distinguish
it from the posterior population and also to collect data for that population.  , each point
represents the signal combination of the corresponding parameter.
Each point in the black line
corresponds to one event or one cell. The
density graph is similar to the 10 graph, but here the signal  Colors are added to show intensity
Two parameter graphs or bivariate function graphs are most commonly used and a
variety of different presentations are possible as the density graph on the left and the ten graphs on the right show
various  different experiments in a population  Fans and gates are used in data analysis to identify
subpopulations of interest. A plate or cell surrounds a population of interest. Regions are used
to delimit specific events or groups within a large data
set.  The
most common application is to use gates in series to define the parameters for limiting the display of data and displaying statistical
data.In
this example, a blood sample containing a mixed population of cells.
As in this example, the analysis can be limited to the Impa grade, and the display of results
reflects the fluorescence properties of only lymphocytes. This is called the lymphocyte gate and is shown in blue in the top graph
.  From this lymphocyte,
Hanyu's three graphs are produced by gating.
Correction is the process of removing fluorescence spillover effects from the rainbow parameter so that the
primary parameter trend values ​​reflect only transient fluorochrome emission
.
A ripple effect occurs when the light of one fluorophore enters the detector of another fluorochrome
. Correction is required to correct for this ripple effect. When the
ripple effect is not corrected, the result is to receive false + and signals.
This process, called compensation, can be electronically removed to eliminate this spitting
effect.Many instruments and software look out for researchers who can perform automatic compensation
.  I would recommend
it, but it's important to understand the basic principles underlying it.
Strong, narrow peaks
, well separated from other emissions, as you can see here,
but in reality, as you
can see in the emission profiles of Alexa bath 4888 r pico l serine rpe, the
fluorochrome emission is much broader.
To correctly interpret the data collected, one must be certain that the trends recorded for the Alexa Bath 488 dye were in
fact
from Alex Fluor occupation and not rpa.
The trend is recorded using an emission filter chosen to collect the maximum amount of light from the fluorophore and
to exclude as much light from other fluorescent molecules as possible,
here with a 530 nm bandpass filter.  It can be seen that the
alexa bath 488 is collected and the
rpe trend is collected by a 8 nm bandpass filter, in
parallel with each filter effectively narrowing the emission peak of the fluorochrome of interest.
The bandpass of 88 also collects some other fluorochromes due to the dense spectral overlap in the reminiscent profile
.
This overlap is shown here in red.
There
is more spectral overlap in the spectral midpoints of the spectrum toward xoflow, and even
greater corrections are
needed to correct for this trend ripple effect.
You should use
either an aliquot of cells individually stained with each fluorochrome
or
a
single-color Taisho-kun labeled with just the microsphere alexa flow dye thinning reagents here
.  is a two-parameter graph where mason shows the pe trend and the x-axis
shows the alexa bath. You
can see both the fairy-marked moon population where the trend is shining and the graduate student population where the trend is not shining,
although these cells themselves  It's also emitting to the rb detector, and as a
result, if you don't correct it, the population will move up.
You can see the story about the cells on the line by looking at the child graph on the left, and
the reason for that is alexa flow formula  This is because the signal from that festival has an emission wavelength that falls into the pe display,
so the graph on the left shows what the monochromatic control sample would look like without correction
.
And when you've corrected for it
, it looks like the graph on
the right
.  can be detected and
correctly assigned to the pe label.
Now let's discuss how to correct
it.
Including combined seconds longitude is associated with a negative
trend  Positive controls can be cells or microspheres
labeled A
single-color positive control is required to set the compensation correctly
For each fluorophore used in the experiment, prepare a sample with only this
Trends are collected from all key channels used in the experiment
This method allows to determine the spillover effect of other off-posting trends
This should be the same fluorochrome
e.g. ap suite alexa flow 6 table  7 is two fluorescent dyes that are collected by the same detector,
but the spectra of these two dyes are different, so
we aim for different correction values.
To avoid this,
it is recommended to use even the exact rod ends
Different rod tandemness may yield different correction
values ​​Beads or cells can be used for different types of positive controls
You can use the same cells as before, but when
the expression of a particular antigen is low or
absent, the cells
can be problematic.  Perhaps due to the number of fairies that were able to use the same drug of death,
these are highly listed.
However, remember that the correction control must be compatible with each experiment and be at least
as bright as the reagents used in the experiment.  In
summary, do you remember the blue control?
You need a single color sample for
each fluorophore in your
experiment.  No
Fairy time experiment and about 2 spectra should fit
plus the positives and negatives should fit the background trend In the
design of the experiment there are some necessary controls to ensure accurate results
We've considered correction controls by
now, plus there's a fluorescence-3 or fmo control, and then there's a biological
control.
The distribution of rowing fields that can prevent high-level signal conditioning
or dispersion of the data can occur.
Including all reagents but one of interest,
fm is called a control, allowing for accurate alignment of conflicts between positive and negative populations.
This method makes adjustments for the variance of the data resulting from correction.
Isotope controls are not specific to the cells of interest within a particular experiment
but preserve the carnivorous properties of the antibody used in the experiment.
They were widely used in the past but are now somewhat controversial.
Purpose  It is to confirm the specificity of primary antibody binding
that is not the result of Hime-specific fc receptor binding to cells
.
Closer examination, if fm by the use of controls,
marker placement is significantly
biologically important at the end.
Biological controls must always be included to ensure correct sample preparation and labeling, and
to perform as expected assays.
Now that you know the basics of flow cytometry
Thank you for your attention.
Now, we have time for some questions.
Thank you for your rich presentation
.
Please type in a box and send it
q In 1 the box can be found by pressing the q & a button on the bottom left of the
presentation screen I believe I have answered as many questions as possible The first question is what is accident tendency  Could you please explain? OK,
self-tendency is a term we use to describe the naturally occurring tendencies in cells.
It reduces the separation and can reduce the
ability to degrade certain particle markers.In
general, large cells tend to be more self-prone than small cells.High-energy wavelengths tend to be more accident-
prone.
What is the reason why is recommended?
The process of finding the optimum concentration for
It may not be suitable for the specific analysis or the particular equipment
you are using. I would say that it is basic to do an antibody titer check. The
procedure is rather simple.
It's important to have equality,
like the time-incubation-temperature reaction,
so the only thing that varies is the concentration of the antibody that you use.
Then you collect these different samples and calculate the
staining index, or
signal-to-background ratio, to kill the device.  About drugs
Finding the best positive-negative separation
I heard that it's important to exclude photoreceptors, what do you mean?
Yes, this is the second question.  It has been shown that
this can display erroneous pixie readings.Therefore
, the use of the small cap foundation is always recommended, especially in imfe's typing experiments
.
There are two different types of cell dyes, the impermeant diffusing base and the amine-reactive dyes
, which are available in a variety of colors to suit your experimental design
.
I have time to ask you one question, what is
sorting? Yes, we haven't talked about sorting at all, but a
sorter is a specialized type of flow cytometer
that separates cells for downstream research.  The
most common type of sorting uses a vibrating device
to break the cell membranes and bring them to mind
. Ideally, there should be one cell for each role.
Trends are measured just before a drop enters the flow. Once
a cell of interest is found, it is given data, sorted
, and redirected for collection.
Now some new sorters are based on microchips.
Thank you very much, Jolin Bradford for your presentation
Thank you again for your
final
words.
Thank you Scientifics Today's webcast
is available on demand until December 28, 2016
so you can replay this webcast without claiming
Lab Tools will contact you by email when it
's done. Please forward this notice to your colleagues who missed today's live event
.